so Studio space you're going to buy a
space to now perform your business out
of you get what we call depreciation
which is just probably the on average
the largest tax deduction you can get so
the business owner should be thinking
how can I actually get some real estate
exactly and what would the tax savings
potentially be
potentially paying zero in tax with
something like that through depreciation
that's how most of our clients that pay
zero it's through some form of
depreciation
welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean Cannell here and I can't wait for
today's featured conversation with Matt
Bontrager talking all about some
Advanced Tax saving strategies some
YouTube tax loopholes and some things
you should know as a content creator as
someone who is starting or building
their business here in the crater
economy about how you can ultimately
keep more money and deploy more of your
money towards scaling your business and
making a greater difference in the world
now today's episode is brought to you by
think cpas.com that's think
cpas.com and uh that is actually Matt is
who we work with from True books as our
own CPA that's just if you want to get
in touch because a lot of people have
discovered that Matt and his team are
amazing and especially for you and me
meaning content creators that are
dealing with unique challenges that we
have is people earning money from
YouTube or affiliate marketing and then
also people that want to be intelligent
and how they're investing their money
specifically in real estate now if
you're meeting Matt for the first time
Matt is a CPA licensed in Nevada and the
managing partner co-founder of true
books an accounting firm specializing in
real estate and it's actually through
Matt's advice that as think media and
our business started to do well that we
also started to deploy and invest
dollars in real estate and specifically
in short-term rentals and Matt's going
to be touching on that in today's
episode and Matt also strives to help
clients navigate complex tax code to
their benefit as well as keeping their
accounting records organized and up to
date he's also a content creator he's an
in-demand speaker for advanced
masterminds and small groups of Business
Leaders and teams and I can't wait to
get into this episode now if you haven't
heard episode one that's here in the
archives wherever you listen to the
think media podcast or watch but episode
2 is really gonna cook your noodle
because Matt shares five specific
Advance things and then towards the
second part of the episode we answer a
couple audience questions and we get
into some nuances I know this might not
be your favorite episode on the podcast
there's other cooler things to talk
about but honestly I feel like this is
one of the best episodes you could
possibly listen to maybe share this with
somebody who needs this information and
maybe take something out to listen to uh
to take notes with and to maybe listen
to this once or twice because it's kind
of like we're going to school but school
is cool the more you learn the more you
earn and that definitely is true about
this episode so let's cut over to the
featured conversation
foreign
[Music]
so we're back in episode two talking
about some YouTube tax loopholes and
some Advanced money saving tips for
Content creators small business owners
online business owners and really how
you can pay less taxes legally and so
we're going to be diving into a couple
strategies I also have some couple
questions to take some of these uh
tactics a little bit deeper as a
reminder this episode is brought to you
by think
CPAs that's the letter CPA s.com think
CPAs that's just a chance if you want to
work with Matt and true books but we
also have other resources we'll
recommend because this can really put
some money back in your pocket more
importantly back in your business but
I'm going to walk you through a couple
of these five Tax Strategies first and
then we'll get into some nuances the
first big one is starting in S Corp why
is that powerful because now you're
taking the LLC or you're starting an LLC
that you never had and you're taxing it
as a separate entity to the IRS which we
can dive into an hour if we want to go
yeah no so break that down for me so
when I do an LLC all I get is a limited
liability company I have some legal
protection if I'm just a sole proprietor
or an LLC I can take a lot of deductions
and write-offs but what's unique about
an S corp that saves me more taxes uh
legally
basically when you're self-employed you
pay self-employment tax which is about
15 we'll say when you're a W-2 employee
you pay seven and a half your employer
pays seven and a half if you're
self-employed you're both so you pay the
entire 15 the S Corp is a great way to
lower the amount of the 15 tax that you
have to pay so if I establish an S corp
what kind of tax savings could I
experience if I was making say fifty
thousand dollars a year as a
self-employed YouTube creator
50 000 would probably save you easily
three grand because the example I used
most of the time is about a hundred
thousand and will easily save somebody
making a hundred thousand six to eight
grand so simply by setting up an S corp
and then running things properly I could
save three thousand dollars that I would
not be paying the IRS that I would
legally be uh just keeping inside of my
business or keeping myself personally at
the end of the year with less taxes
exactly and I want to make it even
easier it's not even setting it up it's
simply a form that your accountant files
telling the IRS your LLC I'd like to
treat it as an S corp think of an S corp
as this hat I'm wearing it's just
something that your LLC now is treated
as so it's you already had the LLC
you're just telling the IRS hey I want
you to treat this LLC as an S corp wow
okay so that's a powerful one number two
set up a solo 401K so solo 401K is great
that's if you're gonna go the retirement
route right so if you're about stashing
some money away for your future a great
way to get a big tax saving so you make
a hundred thousand solo 401K let's say
you want to put away 40 000 bucks I can
now be only taxed on 60 because I put 40
aside wow so uh this also if I start to
have employees I can't do this correct
not a solo okay but you can have a 401k
plan where you offer that benefit to
them too but if I'm truly the only
person working as that you YouTube
Creator I might be working with
contractors yeah but I'm just working by
myself I can now sock away big amounts
of money which I'm not going to pay
taxes on this year now I will pay taxes
when I take it out and I retire but I am
kicking the can by by not paying it now
when I sock that money away exactly
unless we get into a Roth solo 401k and
uh and also if I could be putting money
in my solo 401k and my Roth IRA as well
in the same year right okay and then so
solo one 401K number three is Studio
space what's that because of the magical
word depreciation so Studio space you're
going to buy a space to now perform your
business out of you get what we call
depreciation which is just probably the
on average the largest tax deduction you
can get got it and so does would this
mean if think media bought a building
here in Las Vegas maybe we buy a house
with no HOA so that we can just kind of
do whatever we want with it and we just
devote it completely to the business or
we buy you know something that's more
Zone commercial the key is we have to
purchase it yep you have to purchase so
we actually are purchasing a building or
or a small building of of some kind and
now I'm able to depreciate that so the
business owners should be thinking how
can I actually get some real estate
exactly and what would the tax savings
potentially be
potentially paying zero in tax with
something like that through depreciation
that's how most of our clients that pay
zero it's through some form of
depreciation got it so uh just to kind
of put a little nod to that some people
get mad when they say big uh big people
former presidents pay zero taxes Grant
Cardone pays zero taxes it's because of
real estate and depreciation 100 gotcha
all right number four is the SRT
loophole what's that short-term rental
loophole this is by far the hottest tax
strategy out right now so if you are in
the game of investing in real estate
basically you can buy a short-term
rental
with all debt so meaning you put no
money down or you put a small amount
down and again through depreciation be
able to take this big loss from this
short-term rental and net it against
your business income so you have a
YouTube business doing a hundred
thousand you buy a short-term rental
over here that gets you an eighty
thousand dollar deduction in one year
you now have effectively made twenty
thousand on paper when you really took
home a hundred so this is where your
Genius this is why we work with you too
is because you're where your Genius
comes in because this is an advanced
episode for Content creators the
assumption is probably at this point now
money's coming in oh yeah and what can
happen in content is once really
momentum picks up maybe a lot of money
is coming in so now you're in the higher
and higher tax break brackets maybe
you're in the highest tax bracket plus
you have money to invest and so you're
saying the short-term rental loophole is
if you're being a smart content creator
you're not just letting all that money
sit or just spending that money on a
bunch of stuff that's not write offable
it's that's not a deduction but if
you're if you're smart you're going to
take the earnings and invest it in
something intelligent and if you invest
it in something that's a short-term
rental VRBO Airbnb you there's a Litany
of tax advantages that could happen
there but one of the biggest ones is
that you're you're able to take a loss
how long could you take a loss on it
every year that's what all these big
guys are doing so so actually it might
just continue to take a loss because
your business over here is netting 50k a
year 100K a year multiple hundred
million a year a million a year and so
you're you're able to take a loss and
build up a real estate Empire
theoretically uh and and that's by doing
short-term rentals that's amazing all
right number five and then I want to get
into some questions that came in and
we'll unpack some of these things your
number five strategy that's kind of
advanced money saving tips is bonus
depreciation at a hundred percent what
does that mean so at a hundred percent
means right now if you bought a large
asset for your business a big piece of
of equipment for ten thousand bucks you
would be able to potentially depreciate
or expense one hundred percent of that
asset the reason one hundred percent is
so serious is because it used to be
fifty so similar to meals right it used
to only be 50 of that deduction that you
would get now it's a hundred and that
actually phases out with the recent tax
changes twenty percent per year so next
year it's going to go down to 80. Okay
so
what qualifies that could be written off
with bonus depreciation large assets
like cameras equipment vehicles
um pieces of real estate things like
that and so in the past what the IRS
would would say you needed to depreciate
this over a number of years with bonus
depreciation or accelerated depreciation
means is you're taking 100 right off in
the same year
so here's the mindset that I would
recommend listeners be thinking about
let's say there's you and there's a
competitor and not that everything's
about competition I'm not even saying
that but you wonder why is a person next
to me going so much faster if everything
about our business is kind of the same
we're roughly getting the same views
we're roughly putting out the same
amount of content we roughly are are
doing all the same things
um but you only have so much and we're
making the same amount of money well one
business owner thinks I want to use this
money smart and I want to reinvest this
this money in my business at an
accelerated level
and I want to invest in people uh at
like new gear new laptops new new
equipment I want to invest in a real
estate I want to invest in uh you know
uh cars vehicles for the business and
the other person just goes oh I'm kind
of afraid of making an investment
well they're going to get taxed hard
regardless
but now you fast forward two three four
years the person who did this now has
two Studios four cars and and they're
further along with whereas the other
person just paid the IRS more money
and and didn't expand their business at
the same rate so the mentality this is
how like higher level entrepreneurs
think is they're thinking about okay
these are some advantages that I have
when I save money because I set up an S
corp you know retirement's a little bit
different but nevertheless like you're
you're setting your family up you're
setting yourself up for later but when I
go S Corp and I go Studio space and you
go SRT loophole this is one of the
things we think about you know one of
our team members as we're recording this
is staying in our Airbnb which hopefully
is greater incentive of which by the way
we're when we're actually making no
money for it but nevertheless we have
this asset because we want to bless them
but hopefully think media is a super
cool place to work you got perks you got
incentives you got you know you get to
be in Seattle you're staying like
they're also driving the business car
um and so ultimately
our world is expanding because we are
thinking this way and using S Corp
Studio space bonus depreciation is that
the right way to think exactly every
dollar you spend I think should fall
within one of two buckets to grow your
wealth or to push your business forward
and there's a ton of ways to do that at
the same time so I would honestly say
you could fill both buckets if you spend
your money the right way amazing all
right so kind of in part two of this
conversation
um and then and then we're also going to
be doing a whole third episode and if
you missed part one that's foundational
the third episode we're gonna do more q
a but a couple questions that came in
that were specifically related to this
and if we take it all the way back to
the S Corp uh Joe uh Joanna said
um if I'm setting up my S Corp the
reason you're gonna save money on taxes
is because you're going to set a salary
to yourself lower right because if you
just have a full 100K come in and you
get the full 15 on that entire amount
then that's fifteen thousand dollars
okay in self-employment taxes whereas by
having an S corp the difference is you
can you're assigning yourself a salary
and then you're only going to pay the 50
on a reasonable salary so the question
she asked is what is a reasonable salary
to assign to yourself most of the time
we would aim to do 30 to 50 percent
right some could be higher some could be
lower that's where your CPA is going to
help you find that value because what do
you have to do market research to see
what is someone else similar to this job
what are they making what would it what
would a company pay so in that example
50k okay 30 to 50. so so in that case
you make 100K but now because you set up
an S corp and you are only assigning a
salary of 50k you literally just save 7
500 because you're gonna pay 50 on the
50k salary to yourself but the rest of
the income is related to the business
that's serious money that is seven
thousand five hundred dollars back in
your pocket because of setting it up
right and then assigning a salary to
yourself and make this is also why it's
key the reason we work with Matt as well
we keep great records and we work with
Matt is should the IRS come to us and
audit us we're like call Matt dude
like talk because and and the reason
you're also you you take your job very
seriously is that like you need someone
else because if we're in a fish bubble
and just making it up we're gonna
probably make mistakes and so I like
what you said you're the person you're
working with is going to help you
determine what's reasonable what level
you're at and the nuances are different
like things change you go to higher
levels okay and then does that change
how you file your taxes it does that's
one of the biggest differences now from
going from let's say sole proprietor
single member LLC which is meaning you
just own an LLC yourself to now an S
corp you do have a separate tax return
got it and and does S Corp do you have
to pay estimated taxes you do even when
you're self-employed so no S Corp you
still have to pay your estimated taxes
got it now do some people just not do it
all the time we have a ton of clients to
do it think of it as right it's half a
percent is the interest or the penalty
that the IRS charges so think of it as
six percent annually is what you're
gonna owe as a penalty to borrow that
money and when are estimated taxes as a
business owner do four times a year each
quarter yes okay and so that's a whole
thing but something to definitely stay
in top on top of
um and so Joanna asked you know how much
could I potentially save on taxes well
for round numbers you know if at 100K a
year as uh self-employed YouTube Creator
business owner you pay yourself 50k as
your signed salary you're going to save
7 500 on taxes uh and then she's asking
is that actually the best structure for
my organization at what level would
maybe a different structure be
reasonable
if you're making a couple hundred
thousand dollars net and you don't plan
to take a lot of the money out of the
business a C Corp could work too yeah
but most of the time C Corps don't work
is because you get what's called double
taxation where the business is going to
pay tax and then when you distribute it
to yourself you're going to pay tax so
that's usually not the route to go but
if you're just a cash cow and you're and
you don't plan on needing that cash and
you want to leave it in the business C
Corps have a flat tax rate of 21 percent
so it may make sense sometimes if you're
going to really generate a lot of cash
to just leave it in the business and not
pay tax because notice what I said there
in a C Corp you can leave money in and
you're just hit with a 21 s corporations
a lot of people ask hey my business made
300 and I only took out a hundred am I
only going to be taxed on the 100 pass
through pass through you're taxed on it
all yep and so that's what happens to us
at think media whatever when the clock
strikes midnight when it's December 31st
once we go to January 1st if we didn't
buy the car uh buy the short-term rental
get the laptop if we didn't do it then
it doesn't it doesn't matter whether we
leave it in the business or take the
money as a draw we are hit with taxes
game's over new game started yeah game
over new game started so that is why we
also like to think uh far ahead and why
sometimes especially in December we're
like what's relevant sometimes we as
this goes more into Advanced Tax
planning and strategy but we invested in
marketing there was a company we wanted
to work with it was actually about a
wasn't really marketing but it's kind of
marketing related and it's uh it's kind
of to take it has to do with Heather's
Book Project it's a big it's a big
expense I think it was like 80 grand and
they had the opportunity to you know pay
quarterly and I was like we want to pay
the whole thing it's one of the best
strategies pre-paying expenses yeah we
wanted to pay the whole thing in
December because we're constantly
cooking and now that exact thing is
again you go somebody a competitor
someone next to us they might say oh
that's that's a lot of money but at 37
percent we just saved what thirty five
thousand dollars back in our pocket that
was able to invest towards that so while
someone else is maybe waiting we are
accelerating especially you know you
know we want to pay that whole thing in
full we want to get that thing paid off
this year and so that we can then
actually we are still executing on that
deliverable from them all year long but
we were able to pre-pay okay that's
great now Arden asks
um in the first year of doing YouTube
the amount spent will likely exceed
income so how am I deducting expenses in
this situation
so if you used QuickBooks and you made
two thousand bucks throughout the year
you got deposits you've hit them as
Revenue you're going to show two
thousand bucks on your p l but then
you've bought cameras you've taken
clients to dinners for meals you've
traveled you've went to seminars you
bought education you're part of
Mastermind groups and that has equated
to six thousand bucks you've lost four
thousand dollars that year income two
thousand expenses six thousand you've
lost four thousand on your tax return I
would put that and you would show a loss
and if he does work another job those
are going to net each other out and it's
going to help them pay less tax so right
there it's the best strategy for startup
businesses you're likely going to lose
money in your first year take the tax
advantage can you carry it over at all
any losses you could but it's very
likely he'd get to use it got it so
because carrying it over is that nol net
operating loss got it because uh so
you're probably early on most people
listening to this if you're in that side
Hustle season you've got your main job
your W-2 income the benefit
of your first year of doing YouTube is
actually to deduct your expenses against
and it's understanding that there is a
lot of expenses that can go you can sure
start YouTube with just a smartphone
just hustling on a library internet
connection you can run lean yeah you can
run super lean but some people they want
to really invest they treat it like a
business I want to go to the event I
want to network I want to get on the
plane and go film a podcast with
somebody a video podcast with somebody I
would really want to invest in things
you could do all of that so then his
next question was how much documentation
is needed to prove expenses
so at the end of the day an invoice for
what you paid for is going to help so
that flight that you took to travel to
do your podcast or to film for YouTube I
would keep the itinerary right whatever
receipt you have data is so cheap
nowadays just save it as a PDF on your
computer yeah you know something like
that but at the end of the day just some
form of receipt for what you paid for is
what you need is there any benefit do
you think that my Google Calendar has
any value everything I do for the last
six years is on my Google Calendar huge
that's huge value yeah so where I was
and then why I was there so it's like
yeah you know flew to Miami went to
Mastermind so clear so so even if you
were that's another angle of like what
was this expense and that to hammer that
point if we were an IRS audit and
something got questioned for that date
range let's say travel yeah and you had
a full-blown agenda tied to your
calendar I would legitimately screenshot
your calendar and include that in
documents that I send to an auditor
that's how important and easy it can be
which is is a win win-win-win because
that's like some Heather Taurus energy
on terms of like you should be
organizing your Google calendar and
anyways what are you doing so so to put
it another way right you might if I fly
to Seattle I might say I could even put
on Google Calendar we're gonna go uh
we're gonna be like looking at houses
doing research because we are Real
Estate Investors now in the sense of
Brokers yeah meeting with Brokers
um and and then also having to maybe
visit the house or or do some repairs or
go whatever so just if you are naturally
planning your day anyways uh just doing
that on a week to week basis fast
forward a couple years it's all there in
your Google calendar and we're going to
get into something that really touches
on this which is called material
participation which is tied to that
short-term rental loophole but there's
literally part of that tax code where
you have to track your time we have time
logs that we give people and what better
way to track your time than a calendar
so break that down and this is like
probably the juiciest nugget for me
personally
um because what we realize is one
step one start your business step two
get your business profitable step three
have your business doing relatively well
I think media is doing pretty well and
and has a good net income left over and
so we start thinking how can we invest
in the future how can we also expand the
Empire and so we started we purchased an
Airbnb the key being you also can invest
in
uh long-term rentals however if you're
not actually a real estate professional
which at this point I cannot qualify for
I work too many hours in our business
yep
the loophole is the fact that you get
the benefit of a real estate
professional
even though you are not one exactly but
the key is you have to be materially
involved what does that mean materially
involved is basically on with regards to
that activity being the rental the
Airbnb you run it materially the time
you spend on it is needed to push that
Airbnb forward and to have it operate
and basically that's because rental real
estate is looked at by the IRS is very
passive it's sit back and collect a
check so if you can meet these rules and
have a short-term rental which by
definition avoids the definition of
rental activity with the IRS that's why
it's so important it needs to be short
term to be more specific it has to be on
average seven days or less so the amount
of time you rent the property for your
average stay needs to be seven days or
less and then if you spend time on the
property and materially participate you
can avoid the other rules and take this
and generate this huge loss from this
rental and net it against your business
and so my wife uh she decorated the
house she runs the app she runs the
listings I I took all the pictures for
the listings opened up canva did a sky
replacement on a picture of the house so
the the you know it popped more we're
super host now the whole thing's
happening the big key is we couldn't
take this same uh bonus depreciation and
the some of the and then the write-off
against our business
if it was a long-term rental and that's
where look at it as a game because by
definition that's how we're avoiding and
making this somewhat of a loophole I
honestly think the IRS will close this
they're going to see what's going on and
it's not going to be around for a long
time makes sense and so uh definitely
speaks to the the hustle that we're on
it last kind of question here is uh also
from Arden so he uh is writing off he's
maybe taking he's taking a loss because
his expenses exceed his income in that
first year too of starting up your
YouTube business you keep good
documentation
uh we did talk about this in episode one
but just to hit it to uh in episode two
here how much revenue is recommended
before converting from a sole proprietor
to an LLC in some states LLC fees are
extremely high but there's actually
advantages to just buying like
influencer insurance to cover
liabilities fair so that's where in the
last episode I had mentioned and I'll
stick to it as soon as I'm in the
pursuit of income I'm going to get an
LLC why because it also allows me to get
an EIN which is like a social security
number for my business and then I get a
business bank account those are the
first three steps LLC Ein bank account
but he's right if you want to let's say
you live in California and you want to
avoid that 800 a year franchise fee
that's a lot of money for a new start of
business then I would run as a sole
proprietor which is me doing business as
myself and maybe just getting Insurance
because maybe insurance is 300 a year so
again I'm a fan of an LLC I agree with
that though that you could just run as a
sole proprietor but net income
when that gets around 50 Grand I'm going
S Corp which requires me to have an LLC
at that point yes amazing so a couple
next steps
um you know this was some advanced stuff
definitely uh some advice number one if
you have a listen up part one listen to
part one uh because that's some more
foundational things you might not be at
a place where uh it's not Mo Money Mo
Problems you know but once it's an
important Notorious B.I.G you got more
money you got more problems so you want
to learn Mo text loopholes
and to you know to pay less tax legally
so you can actually solve those problems
because they are solvable but you got to
think at the next level right I think
the another resource that we have for
you is if you actually if you haven't
picked up the recordings from our
Advanced growth video live uh video
success Secrets is actually how they're
packaged and we'll put a link to this in
the show notes
um Matt and Ryan touched on as well you
did a panel and you did a session where
you just broke down a lot of strategy
and tips those kinds of things
interestingly enough and I understand
that this is an online course that we
sell but I think one payment it's 247
right now and but that's a write-off too
you're investing in your education
you're going to learn three days of
marketing information strategy money
making tips how to generate more Revenue
that just goes into it's kind of a I'm
getting off on a rabbit Trail here but
that's why one of my favorite
Investments is my education because it
makes me more valuable I can learn more
but I also can write it off so I like to
travel to events you know I get the
experience but I get to take notes learn
all the things all that to say is again
number one listen to episode one number
two definitely pick up video
successecrets.com because it's three
days of all kinds of stuff including
more business and tax strategy uh number
three connect with Matt on social media
because you know you're gonna need
repetition of this repetition is not
just so that you know it's also so that
you never forget I have been studying
this stuff for over a decade and I still
need to hear it again I call you what's
explain to me again SRT loophole what's
it's a lot so if you already feel
overwhelmed we don't blame you you want
to stay immersed in the repetition of
this information always staying current
and that's why following someone like
Matt is really important so if people
want to follow you where's the best
place to do that Instagram Instagram in
your handle at Matt Bontrager first name
last name awesome so we'll link that up
in the show notes as well and then
finally if you go to think
cpas.com so think cpas.com you can
actually connect with Matt and the true
books team if you're interested in
specifically working with them if not
cool you can work with whoever however I
highly recommend Matt we have years of
experience in friendship now but because
you know he is plugged into not just the
real estate game which is where your
real big tax savings are but also the
content creation game as him and Ryan
work closely together uh as a co-founder
of true books and he there they're just
on the bleeding edge so man your network
is your net worth one thousand you want
to be around people who are plugged in
to SRT loopholes and then when the game
changes you just go wherever the puck is
next and so
um definitely the big recommendation is
either connect with Matt and his team or
find the right CPA and team it's so
worth scared money don't make money it
is so worth the investment I don't want
to pay a CPA I always want to go with
this person because they're cheap you
get what you pay for and you guys aren't
even like expensive it's just a good
investment but it's like I'm looking for
the cheapest CPA is not what the
successful business owner said I'm just
trying to find the cheapest person and
no you want to make sure you have
experts you've got like great people
around you so anyways we'll link up all
those show notes and resources in the
description down below and then make
sure you're subscribed because we're
actually going to be bringing you a q a
episode that maybe touches on a few
details that you asked in the think
media podcast audience and so uh thanks
again Matt for coming on I appreciate it
anytime
[Music]
well I hope you've been getting value
out of this series with Matt just a
couple reminders if you haven't listened
to part one it's here in the archives of
the think media podcast don't miss it
and also if you've gotten value in
today's episode would you consider
sharing this with somebody who would
benefit there has been probably no
greater investment that I've made one of
the greatest Investments that I've made
in my personal life in my business has
been increasing my financial education
and my financial intelligence it's not
my favorite thing to study I would much
rather read a book on social media or on
how to hack the algorithm or hook point
or all these different things but I
found that one of the greatest benefits
for me in my career as a content creator
and in growing think media has been
embracing topics like this and there's
probably a few people you know who are
unaware that they are overpaying in
taxes they are unaware that there's
maybe liabilities to their business in
terms of how it's set up they're unaware
of some of the opportunities that exist
for them to ultimately set up a better
future for their family to make a better
impact in their team to set up a better
future for themselves in retirement so I
really do think that this episode will
be super valuable so think of one person
that maybe would love this and would you
consider forwarding this to them or just
maybe share this on your social media
and tag myself or Heather Taurus or the
official think media account and we'll
link all that up in the show notes so we
know that you got value out of this
particular episode finally if you are
interested in connecting with Matt and
his team at true books just go to
thinkcpas.com that's the word think the
letter c p a s for think cpas.com
they're the CPAs that we use and they've
been nothing but a blessing if you don't
want to work with them cool but one of
the things that I would recommend is we
know after years of working with
multiple different people they're the
most knowledgeable we've ever worked
with and they're hungry I think it's the
fire that I like the most for staying on
the cutting edge of what is happening
right now because Matt and Ryan Pineda
who's a content creator and real estate
professional out here in Las Vegas
because they're doing the stuff their
content creators themselves they run
multiple channels they run multiple
different income streams because they're
absolutely obsessed with passing any
audit and being above board and ethical
in all their dealings but aggressive in
terms of learning and understanding the
tax code so that they can maximize the
savings and use it to their benefit we
we get to draft behind them and we've
experienced countless savings Matt has
literally saved us hundreds of thousands
of dollars and uh I depending on I would
say if you have some momentum and you're
at a place where you're you're ready to
move past DIY or maybe you're just fed
up with your current CPA and you want to
work with somebody better just check out
the show notes or go to think
cpas.com and they just have a special
hookup for think media podcast listeners
my friends thank you for being a part of
the think media podcast we have so many
powerful episodes coming to you soon but
in the meantime I just want to say I
respect you I appreciate you keep
pressing record because there's never
been a greater time to be publishing
content and building a business around
that content as you serve people and
build your income appreciate you so much
we'll talk soon see you in a future
episode